Hi, everybody. Ashley here. Our topic today is allergies and skin conditions. This can be a
histamine genetic defect. So histamine reaction. Histamine initiates an inflammatory response and
that's where we get the symptoms of allergies or a skin reaction. The highest concentrations of
histamine in the body are found in the gastrointestinal tract, lungs, and the skin. When histamine is
secreted, it stimulates gastric acid production and the white blood cells are capable of contracting
pathogens in. The DAO enzyme breaks down histamine to maintain homeostasis and histamine balance.
The histamine and DAO balance is crucial to maintain gastrointestinal and skin health.
So excess histamine can be correlated to genetic mutations, leaky gut allergies, and just an individual's
diet too. Side note, gliadin, which is found in wheat, can also be involved with mass cell
function and the secretion of histamine. That can also be what releases the zonulin and can contribute
to leaky gut. So here are some genetic defects. These are just a couple of the main histamine genes
that we look at during a genetic review. The genetic mutations found in the ABP1 and the HNMT are potential
indicators for elevated histamine. Increased histamine levels can result in heart palpations,
low blood pressure, hypertension, fatigue, anxiety, joint pain, irritable bowel syndrome,
stomach ulcers, adrenal gland fatigue, and altered sleep patterns. So what we can do to fix it
is avoid histamine foods of course, but then these three products can also support those genes.
So histamine scavenger promotes the reduction of harmful histamine accumulation.
Natural dehist supports seasonal challenges caused by common environmental allergens
and histoclear, which addresses the DAO enzyme to balance the histamine load. You can find
these three products at shop.conorsclinic.com. And you can also check out our genetic page on our
website, conersclinic.com as well. If you would like to schedule a genetic review, if you already
have a 23 and me done, I would love to help you out. And we can see if there are other defects in your
genetic pathways that need some support too. Thank you.